Michael and Ava Gardner join us right
now in studio in outfits Michael created
especially for today good morning good
morning thank you for having us thank
you for being here so so in the book uh
Ava is getting ready to perform in front
of her class and you decide to create an
outfit for her to boost her confidence
but the question I have is what inspired
you to start so
so I've been creative since I was a kid
that was kind of my best way to express
myself
um so when I became a father I was
trying to figure out how to navigate
that experience and I figured it made
sense to combine my creativity into the
experience because I feel like that's
how that's the best way for me to
express myself
um and yeah it's allowed me to kind of
grow with her connect with her
um have challenging conversations and
um yeah that decision is kind of where
our bond is
you know and you taught yourself to sew
Michael yes how did you do that what
were you looking at YouTube Pinterest I
love that yep yeah people that take the
time to make tutorials
um you know help me kind of figure out
the process and a lot of trial and error
too I made plenty of mistakes that
people never actually saw so Ava how do
you feel when you wear your dad's
designs
um I feel confident and blessed to have
a dad that takes time to make me close
to build up my self-esteem and
I just really like it and I love
modeling and I love being a part of
daddy dressed me you know what I like
about daddy because you know you you
live in Philadelphia your mom lives in
another state so you you are you're not
a single parent but you're her primary
caregiver because your mom is involved
in your life but I was fascinated that
he does your hair Ava did you did he do
your hair and the makeup before and the
makeup like I'm sorry okay your dad did
that your braids wow Dad how do you do
that yeah talk to me I got a 12 year old
daughter have you ever done her hair
those parts right yeah so let me know so
it kind of started when I was younger
having to look out for my sister
occasionally yeah
um so that's where the first
introduction came but YouTube again
um tutorials on box braids I went on
there learned and again the first few
times wasn't as great as it was it
pretty no it looks great a lot of
practice I was able to kind of figure it
out and I just always want to make sure
that she's good so whatever she needs
I'm going to figure it out I bet it
brings you guys closer too doesn't Ava
together the conversations you must have
yes how so tell me tell us about that a
little bit um so I struggle with anxiety
and that was it became
more when I started having challenges at
school with the people I would hang
around with not knowing if they were
real or fake so I kind of dealt with
that but just talking to my dad makes me
feel a lot better and knowing that I'm
gonna be okay yeah we still struggle
with people who are real and fakie
because you get adults so just know that
so your dad's giving you good training
but part of this for you too Michael is
your own you said own trauma and
childhood and own self-esteem what did
you mean in terms of your parenting yeah
I grew up without my father not really
having discussions about it how it was
affecting me what it meant but I always
knew I wanted to have a family and be a
father yeah
um so but not you know when I decided to
become a father I just had no clue what
to do I didn't have I knew what not to
do yeah
um so I was very I'm very intentional
with her when it comes to how I speak to
her things that I do for her
um even deciding to do something to
build her confidence I wasn't really
confident in myself so through this
process we've both kind of grown
together the book is beautiful it's
terrific beautiful and there's there's a
feeling that you get when you have that
book in the world right it's one thing
to write it it's another thing to have
this company print it and then to have
it exist right how do you feel about it
I'm still processing so it's been out
for about a month now yeah
um but when I started this was actually
a goal like I wanted to have a book
um I didn't have like the exact story
but I wanted to inspire other dads who
were in the same situation as me
um so to now have it be a real thing and
people tell me their experiences it's
it's
a beautiful experience what was your
thinking into the
intimidating Michael and Ava Gardner
um so originally I bought I came to New
York a couple weeks ago bought this
Fabric and was making this jacket for me
and I had some left so I decided to
coordinate her that I recently just
started more so song for myself for most
of the years I've always just sold
forever Ava do you have a style icon
somebody you look at them and go God I
love how fill in the blank dresses you
show that to Dad
inspiration for my dad yeah like
Instagram or something okay
um right so yeah not really from someone
I see but mostly from what he likes what
you're seeing Michael get ready
Michael and Amber Gardner thank you both
very much the book is incredible uh the
outfits are incredible uh daddy dressed
me is available now wherever you buy
your books